well people of the internet there's no
reason there's no point in beating
around the bush here we have yet another
hogwarts legacy rumor here today and it
is not a positive rumor also
unfortunately it is coming from a
credible source we're not dealing in
some random person on twitter anymore
this is actually someone in video games
media who has connections in the
industry and who would certainly know
gosh i can't rig myself to say it guys i
really can't because it's almost
unbelievable but the rumor that we are
hearing is that hogwarts legacy has been
delayed or will be delayed rather
nothing official yet but will be delayed
to 2023. and it comes to us from colin
moriarty of last stand media now if
you're not familiar with colin he
formerly worked at ign and then kind of
split off with greg miller to do kind of
funny then they had a little bit of a
falling out and now he's doing his own
thing at last and media has a huge
sacred symbols which is a dedicated
playstation podcast and if you actually
go looking for this information yourself
you won't be able to find it so it took
me a while to get to the bottom of this
guys i started looking i was listening
to the podcast and like they're not
talking about this at all it's like a
three plus hour podcast so finally i
found a website that actually told me it
is on his sacred symbols plus podcast
which is unfortunately behind a patreon
paywall so here is the quote from the
podcast it says quote i'm hearing behind
the scenes that game is not coming out
this year and that it's in some sort of
trouble close quote and that's really it
he didn't elaborate much from what i was
able to read in these articles now one
thing that i was able to find in one of
his recent public podcasts that is for
anyone to view whether you're a patreon
or not is that he and his co-hosts had
hogwarts legacy on their most
anticipated games list of the year now
this one is sacred symbols episode 183
so it's our most anticipated games of
2022 i'll throw a link down in the
description below but on that episode
they actually talk at length about their
excitement for hogwarts legacy and how
they're looking forward to it so when
you combine that with this news that we
have now this sacred symbols plus
podcast actually came after that one so
it would make sense and i want you to
have that knowledge just so you know
that this isn't somebody coming in
trying to hate and just throw stuff on
the wall and see what sticks colin is
not one of those journalists who's just
going to make stuff up and throw things
out there and post random stuff on
twitter which is the kind of hogwarts
legacy rumors that we've been getting
guys and trust me i hate being the one
to bring this news i really do i hope i
think our hope here is that his source
is actually wrong maybe they heard wrong
but not for one second do i question his
report i think he undoubtedly has heard
this from someone inside the video game
industry i think he probably has a lot
of connections at sony because that's
where his bread and butter has always
been he is a very knowledgeable gamer
and journalist when it comes to
playstation now perhaps adding even more
fuel to the fire playstation recently
posted on their website an article
called 22 and 22 upcoming ps5 and ps4
games to look forward to in 2022 and
they list 22 different games guys that
they are looking forward to and hogwarts
legacy is not on the list now
considering this game was unveiled at
the playstation showcase event for the
ps5 i mean this is not good it's really
not i mean when you take these two
things together i don't think it's a
good sign now i will have to say at the
bottom of this article it says release
dates are subject to change and not all
games may launch in 2022 so sony is even
acknowledging their hey some of the
games on this list probably are going to
get delayed and won't launch in 2022 but
the fact that hogwarts legacy isn't
there at all it's kind of like oh that
makes me a little uneasy but as i always
try to tell you guys i mean i'm going to
try my best to keep it real here you
know this report would certainly go
against kind of that momentum that we
felt like was being built with the
hiring of the community manager with the
posting for the localization job and
then avalanche themselves saying hey
we're going to talk more about the game
in 2022. it has certainly felt like that
things were moving in the right
direction so to me it's not so much the
fact that he says the game could be
delayed it's the fact that he literally
says in some sort of trouble now again
his source could be wrong i don't think
we need to panic or anything like that
but i'm not gonna lie to you guys i
can't just sit here and say that i'm not
concerned at all i think this is
definitely something that we should keep
an eye on and definitely something that
we need to be a little bit concerned
over so as i said in my last video i'm
not going to cover every single little
tiny rumor that pops up because let's be
honest here they're happening almost
every day with hogwarts legacy but this
one here to me since it was from an
actual person that we know confirmed to
be in the video game industry who has
connections i thought we had to talk
about this one so again industry folks
hear things like this all the time
sometimes they're wrong a lot of times
they're not let's just hope this is one
of those instances where they are in
fact wrong and that the game is still
moving forward and still on track to
come out this year i mean it's just
insane if you think about this guys we
are now in january of 2022 a year ago is
when we first got news that the game was
delayed all the way to this year which
is just crazy right i mean we thought it
was going to be 2021 then january of
2021 gets here right away avalanche is
like no we're sorry it's delayed we're
still working on it then we go an entire
year without anything guys without
anything finally at the very very end of
2021 they're like hey more dudes coming
in 2022 they finally said something
which we were very pleased that they
actually said anything at all and now
here we are in 2022 hearing that there
is the potential that the game is
delayed now if you want to get caught up
on all the hogwarts legacy news kind of
a full timeline then check out the
playlist on the left side of your screen
or if you want to take a look back at
the complete history of all the harry
potter video games then check out the
video on the right side of your screen
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon